WEAPONS? IF WE NEVER GET TO
USE
THEM? WELL, OKAY, WE DID ONCE
IN 1945, WE KILLED TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
JAPAN WITH TWO ATOMIC BOMBS.
BUT THAT WAS A ONE-OFF RIGHT?
AN EXTREME SITUATION.
NO ACTUALLY. DID YOU KNOW,
THERE WAS AN ACTIVE PLAN TO
NUKE, MAINLAND CHINA TO, AS
IN THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
US GOVERNMENT WERE PLANNING
FOR AN IMMINENT ATTACK JUST
ABOUT 60 YEARS AGO.
THANKFULLY
PRESIDENT EISENHOWER STEPPED
IN AND SAID IT PROBABLY WASN'T
A GOOD IDEA.
THAT'S THE STORY THAT'S COME
TO LIGHT AS A STILL
CLASSIFIED.
1966, GOVERNMENT STUDY
PUBLISHED ONLINE
IS GETTING INCREASING
ATTENTION. THE UNREDACTED
PAGES SHOW HOW THE US WAS
THINKING ABOUT RESPONDING TO
CHINA IN 1958
WHEN BEIJING BEGAN SHELLING
ISLAND UNDER THE CONTROL OF
CHINA, ALSO KNOWN AS TAIWAN F
WHICH HAPPENS TO BE A US ALLY
IF YOU COMB THROUGH, YOU'LL
READ THAT US. MILITARY
OFFICIALS QUOTE FELT THAT THE
USE OF ATOMIC WEAPONS WAS
INEVITABLE.
AND QUOTE, THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
CHIEF SUGGESTED THAT THIS MOVE
WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY
INVOLVE NUCLEAR RETALIATION
BUT IF NATIONAL POLICY IS TO
DEFEND THE OFFSHORE ISLANDS
THAN THE CONSEQUENCES HAD
TO BE ACCEPTED,
IMAGINE THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF A NUCLEAR WAR
THAT COULD HAVE KILLED
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HERE AND
ABROAD WOULD JUST HAVE
TO BE ACCEPTED AS COLLATERAL
DAMAGE, IN A
CONFRONTATION WITH COMMUNIST
CHINA. THIS SHOCKING
DISCLOSURE WAS QUIETLY MADE
PUBLIC IN 2017,
BY NONE. OTHER THAN DANIEL
ELLSBERG WHO IS NOW. SO,
ABOUT A LOOMING CONFLICT
THAT HE WANTS TO SHARE THE
DOCUMENTS AND THE REVELATIONS
WITH A WIDER AUDIENCE,
THE FORMER MILITARY
ANALYST SERVED AS A SPECIAL
ASSISTANT TO THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT DURING THE VIETNAM
WAR
AND
50 YEARS AGO. NEXT MONTH,
LEAKED THE PENTAGON PAPERS
A CLASSIFIED GOVERNMENT STUDY
THAT HAS THE AP, PUT IT
CHRONICLES DECEPTION AND
MISADVENTURE BY THE
U.S. IN VIETNAM
ELLSBERG MADE COPIES OF THAT
1958 TAIWAN CRISIS OUT THE
AT THE SAME TIME AS HE DID THE
PENTAGON PAPERS
AND NOW GIVEN
IN THAT HEADLINES HERE IN A
BROADER, USING THE W WORD WHEN
IT COMES TO US, CHINA
RELATIONS
ELLSBERG IS HOPING PEOPLE AND
OFFICIALS IN GOVERNMENT PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION
TO WHAT ESCALATING TENSIONS
WITH CHINA
NEARLY LED TO IN THE PAST.
GIVING, YOU ALMOST WENT TO
PRISON. LAST TIME YOU DID.
THIS IS ELLSBERG
AT THE AGE OF 90
READYING HIMSELF TO GO UP
AGAINST
A GOVERNMENT. AGAIN,
DAN ELLSBERG, JOINS ME NOW.
DANIEL, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON THE SHOW,
YOU HELD ON TO THESE
DOCUMENTS.
FOR DECADES AND PUT THEM
ONLINE IN 2017.
THEY'RE NOW GETTING MORE
ATTENTION. WHY DID YOU WAIT
THIS LONG DANIEL? AND WHY DO
YOU THINK NOW IS THE RIGHT
TIME TO BE DISCUSSING? THE
FACT THAT THE U.S. ALMOST
DROPPED A NUKE ON
CHINA
NO, THE TRUTH IS THAT I WAS
PREPARED TO
RELEASE
WHAT I HAD THE
ON NUCLEAR WAR PLANNING
AS SOON AS THE
VIETNAM WAR HAD ENDED. I
WANTED TO DO WHAT I
COULD TO END THAT WAR
BEFORE I BROUGHT
BEFORE I WENT TO PRISON.
AGAIN FOR
ONE BE DIFFERENT GROUNDS FOR
PUTTING OUT THE NUCLEAR
DOCUMENTS. AND WHEN I
WROTE, WHAT
A DRAFT OF WHAT IS NOW, THE
FIRST THIRD OF MY RECENT BOOK,
THE DOOMSDAY MACHINE
CONFESSIONS OF A NUCLEAR WAR.
PLANNER, I SUBMITTED THAT TO
A PUBLISHER.
MY SAME PUBLISHER
TO PUBLISH TO AN EARLIER BOOK
PAPERS ON THE WAR
BACK IN
AND  SOON AS THE WAR ENDED
HER ATTITUDE OF THE EDITOR
WAS
THIS WILL SELL
FOURTEEN HUNDRED COPIES
AND I SAID, WELL
THAT'S ONE FOR EVERY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS AND A LOT OF PRESS
UNDERSTAND WHAT I MEAN. DON'T
THAT MEANS WE DON'T PUBLISH IT
AND INDEED I DID TRY TO
GET THAT WORD OUT
VARIOUS TIMES. THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR, DIDN'T
A BRIEF INTERVAL IN THE EARLY
80S WHEN
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY,
WE'RE MAKING
PUT AWARE OF WHAT A ONE
MEGATON BOMB WOULD DO
TO THEIR CITIES
FOR ONCE. THAT'S THE ONLY
PERIOD IN THAT 50 YEAR PERIOD,
REAL SENSE OF WHAT EAL, HE'S
MEANT THAT WENT AWAY. ALLY
SO THE COLD WAR ENDED THEY
BUT THE WEAPONS ARE STILL R,
THERE. THE PLANS,
THE THREATS OF
A FEEDING TUBE, YOUR FIRST USE
ARE STILL BEING MADE ON BOTH
SIDES SO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS AS WELL AS THE US AND
DANIEL.
SO I THOUGHT THIS IS THE TIME
TO BRING IT OUT IN SHORT.
SORRY,
YOU KNOW IT'S ALL NOT KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THE PLANS ARE THERE
THE BOMBS ARE THERE. YOU'RE
OFTEN ASKED ABOUT BEING A
WHISTLEBLOWER
BUT REALLY BY TRAINING BY
EXPERIENCE YOU ARE A MILITARY
ANALYST AT EXPERT ON NUCLEAR
STRATEGY IN YOUR NEW YORK
TIMES INTERVIEW. YOU SAID
QUOTE, I DO NOT BELIEVE THE
PARTICIPANTS OF THIS PLAN TO
ATTACK CHINA WITH A NUCLEAR
BOMB.
ONE MORE STUPID
OR THOUGHTLESS THAN THOSE IN
BETWEEN OR IN THE CURRENT
CABINET.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CURRENT
US GOVERNMENT,
THE BINDER MINISTRATION
TO BUY DEMONSTRATION, PEOPLE
LIKE SECRETARY
BLINKING AND AUSTIN. HOW
WORRIED ARE YOU THAT SOME
WANT A WAR WITH CHINA THAT WE
MET INCH NEAR TOWARDS NUCLEAR
CATASTROPHE
AGAIN,
THOSE ARE
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE VERY
FEW PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
WANT
A WAR WITH CHINA
AND CERTAINLY NOT A NUCLEAR
WAR
AND YET THEY'RE PREPARED TO
GAMBLE
WITH THE SORT OF
POKE AT THE BEAR IN THE
CAGE OR SOMETHING YOU KNOW TO
SHOW OUR
ANTIQUE CHINA ATTITUDES ARE
COLD WAR AT
ATTITUDES
IN THE NEITHER DEMOCRATS
NOR REPUBLICANS ARE SOFT ON
CHINA, THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
TAKING
A STANCE
HERE THAT ACTUALLY COULD BRING
ABOUT WAR AND
THEN VERY LIKELY WOULD BE
NUCLEAR WAR OVER CHINA
OVER TAIWAN AS IT
WAS IN
1950. IT WAS, WHEN I READ SOME
OF THOSE HEADLINES, YOU JUST
PUT ON
A MONTH AGO
THAT I THOUGHT, WAIT A MINUTE,
THIS PEOPLE HAVE TO REALIZE
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WAR WITH A NUCLEAR
STATE CHINA.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY ACCEPTING
THE IDEA OF
NEW CLEAR WATER, WHICH IS
INSANE.
BUT I WONDER WHAT THE STAKES
ARE FOR YOU. PERSONALLY, WE
ALL KNOW RELEASING CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IS AGAINST THE LAW.
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY, THE DOJ
COULD COME AFTER YOU UNDER THE
ESPIONAGE ACT FOR DOING THIS,
WHICH
BELIEVE. SO YOU CAN CHALLENGE
THE DOJ HAS PRACTICE
OF USING THAT ACT TO GO AFTER
WHISTLEBLOWERS. YOU WANT TO
TAKE ON THIS RISK? SO WHAT IS
ARE YOU, HOPING WILL HAPPEN?
I HOPE THAT PEOPLE WILL ON
THE ONE HAND ON THE,
ON THE TRIAL. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT WHAT I'VE JUST
DONE
IS
AS INDICTABLE
AS, IN THE EYES OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, WHICH
I THINK IS ON THE WRONG TRACK
HERE,
IN THE VIEW OF OUR FIRST
AMENDMENT.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE
PROSECUTION'S, THEY'VE BROUGHT
IN THE LAST 20 YEARS,
ESPECIALLY STARTING WITH
INTO TRUMP AND NOW  AND
INTO BIDEN, WHO IS STILL
PURSUING?
THE EXTRADITION
OF JULIA,
CHALLENGE. THE FACT IS JULIAN
ASSANGE.
GIVE THAT AS A PUBLISHER
PUBLISHING. THIS THERE IS NO
BASIS FOR FOR
INDICTING.
JOINING.
THE SCIENCE THAT DOESN'T EXIST
FOR THE NEW YORK TIMES NOT
BUT WHAT I JUST PUT OUT,
THAT'S
AN I AM NOT INVITING
AN INDICTMENT OF NEW YORK
TIMES. I THINK THAT WOULD BE
BAD FOR THIS COUNTRY,
BUT I AM WILLING TO RISK.
SOME INDICTMENT OF
MYSELF.
AND YOU'RE A BRAVE MAN FOR
SAYING. SO IN DOING, SO
YOU MENTIONED THE ASSANGE
EXPEDITION IN THE
BINDER. MINISTRATION, YOU
SAID, IN A RECENT INTERVIEW
WITH THE INTERCEPT THAT I
DIDN'T START LEAKING, I WAS
THE FIRST PROBABLY TO DO A
MASS RELEASE AND I WANTED MUCH
MORE OF THAT TO HAPPEN AS A
RESULT MORE HAS HAPPENED. OF
MANNING AND EDWARD SNOWDEN,
JULIAN ASSANGE REALITY WINNER,
THE LIST GOES ON BUT
MANNING SPENT SEVEN YEARS IN
PRISON
ASSANGE AS HE PUBLISHES YOU
SAY IS FACING EXTRADITION.
WINNER IS STILL IN PRISON
SNOWDEN, WON'T RETURN FROM
RUSSIA, UNLESS HE'S ABLE
TO ARGUE A PUBLIC INTEREST
DEFENSE. HE SAYS TO A JURY
WHICH THE CURRENT ESPIONAGE
ACT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
AND WHICH JOE BIDEN SUPPORTS,
AS YOU SAY,
DO YOU BELIEVE THERE IS AN
ONGOING WAR ON WHISTLEBLOWERS?
WHISTLEBLOWERS, INCLUDING FROM
LIBERALS?
YES,
ONE HAS TO SAY THAT
IT WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO
CAMPAIGNED ON TRANSPARENCY
IN GOVERNMENT AND DID NOT
DELIVER ON THAT AT ALL
IN FACT, HE
INDICTED AND PROSECUTED
THREE TIMES AS MANY
CASES AS ALL
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS PUT
TOGETHER.
NOW, THAT EARLIER PERIOD WAS A
SMALL NUMBER BECAUSE IT REALLY
VIOLATES OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION. BUT NEVERTHELESS
HE BROUGHT EIGHT OR NINE OR
10 DEPENDING HOW HE COMES.
THESE LIKE
GENERAL PETRAEUS
IS A WHISTLE-BLOWER EVEN FOR
SIMPLY GIVING
HIGHER THAN
TOP SECRET INFORMATION, MUCH
THE HIGHEST WE HAVE
CULVER IDENTITIES OF COVERT
AGENTS IN THE DOCUMENT HE GAVE
TO HIS
BY VERBAL BIOGRAPHY FOR HIM.
YOU GOT A SLAP ON THE WRIST
FOR THAT. NOW WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO INDICT
PETRAEUS LIKE, WELL, HE DIDN'T
PUBLISH ACTUALLY WANTED
HIS BIOGRAPHER TO
PUBLISH WHAT YOU DIDN'T DO.
DO IT BUT REALITY WINNER WHO I
THINK WAS A WHISTLEBLOWER
HERE.
NOW THE OTHERS YOU'VE PRISON.
MENTIONED, ED SNOWDEN
IN PERMANENT EXILE.
THE
FOR ME, OF COURSE, IN 90,
THE PROSPECT OF A SENTENCE,
SUCH AS I FACED IN
1971, WHICH WAS
PRISON OR AND FIFTEEN YEARS IN
ASSANGE IS FACED WITH RIGHT
NOW,
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY-FIVE
YEARS IN PRISON
LIFE SENTENCE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE SAME FOR
ME
AT 90S,
IT MEANS FOR THEM,
PRISON AT ALL. BUT IN A WAY
FOR 50 YEARS,
I'M GOING TO LEAVE HIS BEEN MY
RETIREMENT PLAN
AND WE DO
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE YOU
IN PRISON
AS A RETIREMENT PLAN, OR
OTHERWISE, ONE LAST QUESTION.
BEFORE I LET YOU GO. WHEN
QUESTION, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
WE'RE LIVING IN A VERY ENT.
DIFFERENT
ERA FROM WHEN YOU RELEASE THE
PENTAGON PAPERS BACK IN
1971, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
U.S. TODAY,
SO POLARIZED, SO DIVIDED
PEOPLE IN THEIR OWN
INFORMATION.
BUBBLES,
AL'S IN SOCIAL MEDIA
SILOS, DO YOU THINK A
MODERN-DAY VERSION OF THE
PENTAGON PAPERS WOULD HAVE
HAVE THE SAME IMPACT TODAY,
DISMISSED BY PARTISANS? WHO
DON'T LIKE THE FACT IT DOESN'T
FIT THEIR POLITICAL NARRATIVES
OR IDENTITIES.
ABOUT THE GREAT DIFFERENCE
FROM NOW
I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHAT A TIME
TAKE IT BUT IN 1971, UNG, I
IS COUNTRY WAS POLARIZED
ABOUT THE PENTAGON ABOUT THE
VIETNAM WAR AND
I WAS CALLED
A TRAITOR
BY VERY, VERY WIDELY
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE TREES HIM
IS A VERY
CONSTITUTION AND I DIDN'T,
I DIDN'T FIT THAT
BUT AS OF TODAY
IT'S A VERY GOOD.
WE ARE STILL MAKING
THE THREAT OF INSANE.
THE THREAT OF NUCLEAR.
ATTACK.
ATTACK
FIRST
USE OF NUCLEAR ATTACK TO
INITIATE A NUCLEAR WAR IN A
VARIETY OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE MADE THAT COMMITMENT TO A
LOT OF ALLIES AND WE'RE
IN PROCESS, THE
TEAM'S OF TREATING
OF TAIWAN WHICH THE CHINESE
REGARD AS PART OF CHINA
MOVING TOWARD REGARDING THEM
AS HAVING THE SAME
OF INITIATING NUCLEAR WAR, O
IN THEIR DEFENSE, THAT'S THE
PROMISE OF AN INSANE
ATTACK
PROMISE WITHIN THE
SANE RESPONSE HIM. IT'S I
THINK THAT IT NEEDS.
YES, THAT SHOULD THEY SHOULD
BE DISCUSSION. THAT SHOULD BE
DEBATE. IT'S INSANE TO BE
THREATENING NUCLEAR WAR OVER
ANYTHING.
DANIEL ELLSBERG, WE APPRECIATE
YOU COMING ON THE SHOW.
RELEASING THESE DOCUMENTS
PRISON AND WE THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE
THROUG
UTYO YU OUSOR  MCAUCREH,ER A. P